Here's the Graphpad website. We want to calculate P from our T statistics. And
again, we want to calculate P from T, so that's this first option. And here we
got that our T statistic is 0.977. And our degrees of freedom is 7, because we
had 8 values. Compute P, and indeed, we get that our P value is between 0.3 and
0.4, 0.3611. And the website even tells you that by conventional criteria,
usually by alpha level equals 0.5. This difference is considered to be not
statistically significant. We got 0.3611. This is not statistically significant
and that's because the probability is greater than our alpha level. Remember
that our alpha level is 0.05. Therefore, we fail to reject the null. We're
sticking to the assumption that the population that our sample is from, is not
significantly different from 10. Great job.